going over
again
this
side control basics
weight
needs to be directable
it's not just weight on him but wait
where it's to your advantage
and wait
not where it's to your disadvantage so
you have the spine and you want to
understand
the point of no return
regarding your balance okay so even
though you're on the ground there's
still balance and still the tactic
of attacking balance okay so for example
if i bring my weight
too far over his spine it's easy for him
to take my balance this way
all things being equal
if you can
be aware of that center line
all things being equal if you can
place your way to attack his respiratory
system
so solar plexus
diaphragm
chest
abdominals
best diaphragm solar plexus but
sometimes you don't have that because
you're up high
then try to compress this chest
sometimes you can't do
solar plexus diaphragm because you're
down low and try to stop the expansion
of the stomach
so we're working
this basic side control
we're going to work the principle of
don't create space
create space
he can move
he can move he can counter if he can
counter he can attack
so don't create space
you create space you're going to violate
the first rule too you're not going to
have weight on the guy
okay
so i'm up close
up close a lot of times you think this
is close and this is not close there's
space there see i can fit my hand in
close close close
close
okay
third principle
you can also use your weight because
it's mainly produced by the majority of
your mass
in an attacking way
so here he has a common frame
and you can attack the frame with your
weight
you know that he's strongest he has the
most leverage on his center line
a frame that's too far out is not afraid
okay
so i can put my weight in a way
that i
create that mechanical disadvantage on
that but i do with my body how i'm
putting my weight there
next you can make yourself uh when you
put your weight you can use your
musculature to pull him into you pull
you down to him but you don't want to
burn out your arms so you'll do it by
reinforcing your grips and things like
that okay
and lastly what we're going to work on
here
is that you can
make him uncomfortable
by little minor tiny attacks
with what you can do with your secondary
weight so your primary weight is
probably going to be
about attacking the respiratory system
if you can then
start deleveraging him
and then three use the remainder of your
weight
to uh start disrupting him okay
one way to disrupt is to take away his
posture
so right now he has spinal alignment but
we're going to take this posture away
this way and this way okay
and expose the carotid here
so i'm going to come
underneath i was close and i put my
weight on him weight is being directed
on him don't go too far
wait on him
my legs are floating as much as possible
it's on him
we're going to secure our grips
here
so i can use this to bring him into me
and pull him down to me
i'm going to use the other hand to start
doing that third thing i'm going to
start deleveraging him so he's trying to
get his frame and i'm going to attack
this elbow space here
then i'll do that last thing where i
secure my grips
and i'm close it's helping me stay close
and then with the remainder weight i'm
going to put it into his jaw hinge
carotid area
it'll go like this
make sure your head is down
if you're doing all this and we ask the
question
can he get to a weapon
can he get to my weapons
can he punch me
the answer is no okay so you if you do
all these principles
the way you're supposed to you it's
already ready built to address strikes
and weapons okay
so i'm here like this
he tries to move his hands it's not so
easy
he can't move his body i'm all there
and the whole time it's hard for him to
breathe
and he's feeling this pressure
right here with my shoulder okay so
again
because we train in the beginning
without strikes
you tend to milk the techniques
and you're doing things like this
you see and that arm is not attacked and
he can get a weapon from his waistband
and now stab me and i have to try to
defend you're not going to defend you're
going to get stabbed okay
so
although he has the frame it actually
helps check weapons okay
so let's get into that position and get
those principles going
okay so he's
gonna go
i'm framing so
right
um
let's come around
okay
right here there's space
you see
try to get rid of that
there you go you see that difference
no we're not done
turn this way
okay get rid of that hip space
there you go there's space here though
you see right okay so if you have stuff
on you
right
or i already had the weapon in my hand
you don't want that
get this arm trapped put your weight on
it there you go there you go okay stay
there stay there pay attention
go pressure okay
so look out here
you see all right
pin it pay attention
drive your shoulder anymore go back
first thing is take my head
and take it more off my alignment do you
see that now drop your head
so that that arm can't come out
you're losing this pressure again put
that hip underneath me
there you go
good
just
okay same thing there's a lot of space
here a lot of space get rid of it
tighter
now this hip down here go back this way
put it on
okay so same thing look
drop your stomach more
drop your stomach
now you're watching the point of no
return
there's too much space look two months
you see
that
watch the point in the return
if they're stronger than you go back
put it there maybe someone your size
that's gonna be okay but i am stronger
than you and i'll get a bridge and your
own
the point of no return is relative to
your opponent
okay see this space where i can move
that's where i can get my knee in
you see the knee is in and now
get rid of it
get rid of this space
drop your head
it's still there
you're not sure what to do
this space right here
get rid of this
and go change you're lost
[Music]
wait
so you're here
watch what i'm going to do watch what
i'm going to do
do you feel that little weight shift
okay
you try to move that knee in there
do you see
got it
try to pull your arm out
try to pull the other arm out
do you see
okay
let's go
when you transition
you have to keep employing control
maintenance
it does not make sense that
you would transition
and lose more control
than you had if if what i have is
greater control
then i have the advantage don't move
into a position of disadvantage okay
but oftentimes because we're
transitioning our mind gets
fettered and you're letting control
points off okay
keep your mind present fluid and release
and as you transition it should actually
get more control otherwise i wouldn't
have transitioned okay
so i'm in that same position
and he feels the weight and the pins
that he feels
and he's going to feel more
as i step to here
everything got tighter that space that
he was having a problem with
that space as tight as i have it now
it's gonna get tighter
okay and what am i attacking here
his stomach
he's harder for him to expand
this isn't it
drive that knee
in and up
pull this
into that knee
as you're going
you don't want this arm to come out
go back
so continue to use your head
to trap it
he tries to pull the arm out
it's not coming out
continue the attack you have
on this arm
as it's going up
okay
this elbow is now supporting too much
weight
of my own weight
because the length of my upper arm
so take it out of the way
one
and that's going to put more weight on
him
weights dropping on him
use your hands to turn yourself
keep this
foot
high outside of his half guards
and rotate
this weight
on him
through this wide base
the foot is down
then you can attack this arm
boom
this way
and now you have
a high mount
okay
we'll stop at this point
here
climb up
and do it again
don't give up any control don't let him
have his arms to punch or draw weapons
pull your arms out
shift to get that foot past the half
guard
start attacking this arm
this way
same thing my weight on that arm
pull your arm out
can't pull him out
can't draw a weapon can't take my
weapons
get to there
okay he's gonna go again you can see so
i can start grabbing on his weapons
get this arm trapped
put your belly on it
go
look
so here i grab
and he's not gonna have a very good
transition
okay you grab his testicle
let me out
and again the principle is i move to
tighter control not less control
he goes
yes there you go like look you forgot do
you see
and there's my weapons
boom
get that trap
continue
weights off me
wait on me oh and here i am again
so i'm grabbing your testicles you're
not gonna have a fun time
control my arms i'm out again
i'm out again these are all my weapons
that i'm drawing okay
good
continue
tighter control
that's it feel that arm on your belly
use your head to trap this hand
there you go
good don't pull it out that far go back
start attacking this there you go
warm weight on me
don't yes good
continue it should get heavier heavier
yes
go back
good
good it got tighter
attack the arm right there no need to
spread out that far you're thinking of
widening your base
but you have you can only widen it then
you can keep the trap on my right arm
okay okay and you go
good same thing you don't need that much
space
put that arm near me
good
good start paying attention to this one
see your knee your left knee
get that underneath my elbow and now
start shoving it up
by while pinning it no that's speed
go back
speed requires that you're faster than
me speed also requires that i'm not more
sensitive than you do you understand go
back rewind
okay so you go
that's space i'm
not feel it under your chest
you feel the hand under your chest
drop your head down
and now trap it the bottom there you go
okay when you come up don't take this
weight off my hand as you attack my
elbow with your knee
okay
go
that's it look though look where's your
weight on your head
okay
okay let's go
so in the same way
that i can start
pressuring
disrupting
i can start isolating
okay and that's what we're going to do
now okay
so
pressure
tight
boom
i'm checking i'm going to check this arm
between my chest this i'm talking to you
between my chest
your elbow
my forearm
and my head now it's trapped
you see
pull it out
okay
i take one of those away pull it out you
see put it back
take another one pull it out do you see
do another one pull it out yeah you see
boom
keeping it all on
feel your other arm
this arm
inner thigh
chest
you see
and proximity pull it out
see now as i go i start isolating
pull your bottom arm out
pull it out
you see
feel what's trapping
it i go over
pull out your bottom mark
now i have isolated
the right arm
down it goes
pull the bottom arm out
you see
pull the top arm out
easy
okay let's try it
okay
you see him
so you gave me space do you see
i'll let you get past that
which you're not right okay go
here i am again
you see
oh
again it's maybe your firearm or your oc
you get it or your knife
or
my knife do you see
let's let's disrupt my posture
get my head over here
drive that shoulder in
again that's a bad technique but go
ahead
you see you're creating space around you
see and you're bringing your butt higher
and you're putting your weight on your
knees
when you bring your knees together and
so weight is off of me okay
go ahead we'll get you past that go
yep go ahead
okay there you go right and i'm back out
again
do you see
so
here here you even have the mount
reversal don't you right
so you go
that front leg is too low right
like get this on i don't have it
it's too much space this art leg up here
and you should have been attacking this
elbow hi
there is it trapped okay but what about
this one
here's my weapon again
trap it
what is this hand doing the sand is
doing sport jiu-jitsu
do you see cause my hand is out there's
my knife boom
dead
get it
no
all right let's go
okay
get this arm
space again
you see
reinforce
space again
space again okay
let's get the drill going
you all know how to go from side control
to mouth
mean you know the roadway
okay
but you've been milking no weapons no
strikes
okay so use the roadway
but now tune it properly to
weapons and strikes are not relevant
because they are taken care of
along the road
okay